what's your biggest screenwriting regret
that i didn't move to la sooner i had my
first opportunity to move to los angeles
in 2009 i think it was
um i was working on i was still living
in michigan at the time
working on movie sets as a production
assistant and
myself another pa
and a makeup artist we're all discussing
moving out here together
then one of them had a uh
a sudden like immediate death in the
family that
now they and and so now they had to be
the sole provider for their family
um and so they really okay now i can't
make the jump out to la
and without them the other person was
like
well i don't want to go if she's not
going to go kind of thing you know and
so left just me and i could absolutely
afford to
still come out here on my own because i
had saved up all the money from like the
five or six movies i
and and two tv shows that i had paid on
out there
but i just didn't i i don't know
it was it was one of those fear things
where like it was a
fear of the unknown sort of thing you
know whereas like i was gonna be fine
coming out here with them as like a um
like a safety net sort of thing because
at least i would know somebody because i
didn't know anybody out here and so
i didn't have the courage the film
courage
to come out to la when i could have the
first time
and so it ended up like losing me you
know so many years because the time i
did move i was 2016
you know so now it's like i've lost like
eight years of
potential experience i could have had
out here well there was a lot of fear in
2009 because the recession
right so a lot of people didn't know
still what was going to happen
and a lot of speculation so
you know i wouldn't beat yourself up
over that it was a scary time yeah
sure and and it's one of those things
where you could
you know you could talk yourself up
about any bad decision you make
and and make it seem like oh well it's
understandable that you made that choice
at the end of the day i wussed out i
should have just
come out here um obviously certain
things would have gone differently i
would have never met my fiance
okay i love you um
you know and and stuff and or maybe i
would have but
you know by that point i would have been
hopefully bigger by now
um but it's one of those things but like
i
i feel like it was a missed opportunity
that i could have
started my life much sooner i guess um
rather than you know i would would have
been in my 20s
out here i could have gotten a job you
know as as like a either an assistant
somewhere
you know whether it be a pa on a set or
being an assistant like in an office or
something like that
um but now nobody wants to hire a 36
year old
person you know as like the bottom level
thing because like the pay is like
minimum wage at this point you know it's
like when i'm 20
minimum wage is fantastic i can live on
minimum wage of course there's ramen
noodles
what can go wrong now that i'm in my 30s
minimum wage would kill me you know i
would never be able to afford my
apartment on minimum wage i've
couldn't you know hold up my my current
standard of living and stuff now
so it's like i feel like i lost out on
the chance
to live within the means that i had when
i was in my 20s
rather than the means that i've procured
over the years with the experience
now so i have more life experience but
it's less
experience i could have been sharing in
hollywood and moving up the ranks
already so it's like i'm already
starting at square one
in my mid-30s rather than in my mid-20s
well this is total cliche but i don't
know if i always believe this but this
is the cliche saying everything happens
for a reason
i don't always subscribe to that and i
know it's just like can i get any
cheesier but
right um if we take that and dissect it
as much as it should be like on a mug
and you know somebody in front of
somebody's computer
do you think that's true or do you think
that we tell ourselves that
i think it's a combination because
obviously you can't it depends
if you believe in fate i guess um
i'm not a big subscriber in fate because
it takes away any choices i would have
had i guess
um so on on on that side like
it's not it doesn't work out
that everything's supposed to happen the
way it's supposed to happen because you
don't know how it's supposed to happen
that's true um and you can also
if things happen in a different order
you're gonna have a different place so
it's kind of a thing of
you would have a different life which
life would be better the life you
would have had or the life you do have
um
so i don't really know it i don't know
where i would end up you know like
having been an extra eight years in los
angeles would i now be the next shonda
rhimes
or would i still be travis sepala trying
to be
shonda ryan you know like um would i
have a lovely gorgeous fiancee
or would i be alone or would i have a
different fiance
would i be hooking up with actresses
there's no way of knowing well this is a
screenplay right here okay
okay you know it's um i think there's
actually a script that i just read
um it was a pilot for this current pilot
season i don't know if i got picked up
or i think he got picked
bought picked up the pilot they haven't
announced it it's going i think it's
still shooting
i can't remember the name of it i'm
terrible at remembering titles but
it is a script that follows along this
character
and he makes he the show starts with him
at like a crossroads where he has
the option of either after his
graduation of either
going with his parents going with his
friends or going with this girl he likes
and then the story from there tri-sex i
guess you call it since he has three
different paths
what his life would be in each of the
scenarios oh and so yeah and so the show
kind of
goes along that where like it'll be like
seeing him
uh you know the the path where he went
with his parents because his
his dad and his granddad were both cops
now he becomes a cop
and so it follows along him being a
detective now in in this
in the city the path where he went and
followed
his friend is he went uh because he had
graduated with a
medical license he went and just you
know became a doctor and now he's a
doctor
and then the third path is he end up
like opening his own business and is
living with
the girl now and stuff and all three of
them have the
have the identical overall um
scenario that is happening and how it's
happening differently based on where
he's at
so for instance in the pilot episode
which obviously i haven't read past
pilot because it hasn't gotten picked up
yet
is there's a congressman who gets
assassinated that in one aspect
as the cop he's you know following the
assassination and trying to solve it
when he's a doctor he actually saved the
senator so he didn't die from the
assassination attempt
and then with the friend or when he has
his business order he's in the wrong
place the wrong time and he gets killed
instead of the
or he gets shot rather and has to go to
the hospital and stuff
and as it shows like how his life would
be
drastically altered in these three
choices so i don't know where the show
is going to go from there but the pilot
i was like oh my god this is brilliant
like and and that kind of goes along
with what you're saying of like
you know would it be better like was i
determined was i
destined or determined to be where i am
now versus
had i made the choice to come out here
when i could have it follows along that
same thing as this tv pilot of like
there are different
forks in the road and each one leads to
a different place you know if you want
to go
with science fiction or um
physical uh quantum physics and stuff
you know of like
multiple parallel earths you know
there's the the multi-earth theory where
the
an earth exists for every possibility so
any choice you've ever made in your life
it automatically created new parallel
universes you're in the one where you
made your choice but then over here you
made the other choice
and there's infinite number of those and
so
i don't mean to go all quantum network
and stuff but uh
you know it's one of those things i
don't know if i think i'm destined to be
anywhere because there's so many
outcomes that are possible i don't know
if i'm in the best place or if i would
have been in the best place or if
they're still best place or if
what's happening i think we can all look
at our lives and say well
if i just done this earlier but we don't
know
if we'd done it earlier maybe we
wouldn't be prepared to handle certain
things
but you would also be in a different
place entirely and
would have like for instance i had one
choice that i could have made
the choice i made was to stay in my
hometown and
go to work and be a sous chef in my
hometown or
i could have gone to yellowstone
national park and ben
started off as a dishwasher there and
worked at the rinks
how would things have changed if i would
have not stayed home with my parents and
gone to
yellowstone you know like who would i
have met who what would i have learned
what would have happened to me you know
i would be a very different human being
with that experience than i was staying
home working in a local restaurant
so i don't know if coming to la eight
years earlier when i could have
would have made a huge impact or if it
were
either for the better or for the worse
you know right
yeah i don't think for any of us we we
totally know yeah
do you think a great writer will live
forever through their work i'm gonna say
it depends on the story
we remember f scott fitzgerald
for the great gatsby but he wrote so
many other things that most people don't
even know exists you know he wrote other
novels he was even a tv writer
nobody could i could never tell you what
episodes of anything he wrote
but i know he wrote television uh but
it's like everyone remembers him because
the great gatsby like is
all prey at the altar of gatsby sort of
thing you know so
but if if if he hadn't written the great
gatsby he's still a great writer and
wrote all the other stuff but nobody's
ever read this other stuff
so and and i also feel that
it depends how timely it is versus like
current locale i guess um stuff i write
today
20 years from now are gonna seem blase
and
like out of place and out of touch and
and everything you know like we're
we're in in like a field now looking at
comedy for instance
stuff that is funny now
[Music]
won't be funny later like you look at an
old simpsons episode
from like the early 90s it's not funny
anymore and
is kind of like racist in parts you know
the whole thing with
apu the character that they're
apparently axing a poo completely or
whatever
because people are complaining that it's
racist but those complaints were
probably still there in the 90s we just
didn't hear them as much because
the internet has grown and people um
become more vocal
on their you know and are able to have a
place to
defend so like for instance when i was a
kid
um me and my sister are are big fans of
a christmas story
laughed my butt off at the end scene
when you know when they're in the
chinese restaurant but now that's like
the most racist scene you can imagine
basically you know and it's like it was
still racist then but it was like
you didn't it was like we didn't know
better i guess as a society
and the way that we have a society have
evolved made it obsolete and
crass and should not be laughed at
anymore
so things from now may not live on
you know beyonce so like you could write
an amazing story but 10 years from now
your story may have
zero relevance sort of thing
you